- Bonjourno, buon anno!
- C'est une tradition au
Vatican, mais ces prières
de l'Angélus pour marquer
le Nouvel An. Des cérémonies
qui, cette année, prennent
un sens particulier. Le pape
François a de nouveau souligné
la mort de son prédécesseur,
survenue la veille.
Dès lundi, les fidèles
pourront se recueillir devant
la dépouille de Benoît XVI,
premier pape émérite
de l'histoire. Depuis
sa renonciation, il y a
presque neuf ans, deux papes
ont cohabité au Vatican.
ROMILDA FERRAUTO, adjointe dir.
Bureau presse du Saint-Siège
- C'est vrai qu'ils sont très
différents entre eux. Ils
sont très différents, par
tempérament, culture, mais
en même temps, Benoit XVI a
préparé le terrain, y compris
avec sa renonciation.
- Cette experte évoque
notamment ses interventions
à propos des abus sexuels
et des scandales financiers
secouant le Vatican.
Des dossiers qui ont par
ailleurs miné le pontificat
de Benoit XVI.
Sur la place Saint-Pierre,
certains croyants tiennent
à rendre hommage à ce pape
plus discret que son
prédécesseur Jean-Paul II ou
encore son successeur François.
"Il a beaucoup fait pour
l'Église catholique",
dit cet homme.
- Non, parce que c'était
quelqu'un qui était assez
profond, qui avait... qui
théologiquement étaiititititit
quelqu'un de très important.
Et après, je trouve qu'il a eu
la dignité de passer la main.
- Beaucoup ont été marqués
par cette démission surprise
de 2013. Un geste qui n'avait
pas été posé depuis plusieurs
centaines d'années. Mais
l'ancien souverain pontife
ne faisait pas non plus
l'unanimité.
- Cette catholique rappelle
qu'il était conservateur,
alors qu'elle croit que l'Églis
devrait être plus progressiste.
Le départ de Benoît XVI
permettra-t-il à son successeur
François de réformer davantage
l'institution? C'est possibl
croit Romilda Ferrauto.
- François, quelque part,
aura les mains un peu plus
libres. Bon, ce n'est pas
très élégant, je suis sûre
que François souffre de la mort
de Benoît XVI, mais c'est vrai
qu'il y a peut-être des ch
qu'il n'a pas osé faire par
respect pour son prédécesseur.
- Mais, l'heure est avant
tout aux hommages. Jeudi,
c'est le pape Fran
présidera les funérailles de
son prédécesseur Benoît XVI
sur la place Saint-Pierre.
Une scène qui n'avait jamais
été vue da h h h h h h histoire
de l'Église catholique.
Ici, Raphaël Bouvier-Auclair,
Radio-Canada à Rom